I'm sure the subject matter itself
probably just lends itself to being
memorable but reading it and worrying
about it was very different from
actually just doing it take off your
clothes your body belongs to the state
since your birth the state narrative now
the state asks something in return when
you're on set they're very good about
closing it off there's really not a lot
of people and the only people who were
there there were people who have known
since Hunger Games you know the camera
guys at AG and Francis obviously it's
one of my favorite scenes that I've ever
shot to get a scene like that to work
took a lot of conversation and thinking
once Jen signed on to do the movie
knowing that that scene was there she
became a partner in a collaborator
specifically about any of the scenes
that have difficult content and it's
something that so easily could feel
gratuitous and instead I think feels
really empowering you are better at this
than any of us
yes a gift and also going into the movie
I had promised her that she would be the
first person to see the movie before the
studio and the producers even so that
she always had first right to kind of
Nyx
anything you know just tried to empower
Jen as much as possible to feel like she
could be as brave as possible and give
her control they did an amazing job of
making me feel very comfortable and
what's funny is like you know shooting
it was very graphic and then when I
watched it it's actually really not as
Francis is so tasteful that I was almost
offended I was like I gave you both and
he used one
you
[Music]